hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are looking at horizon zero
dawn in about ten minutes this will
contain spoilers so if you plan to play
this game then give this video a Miss
until the DLC rolls out horizon zero
dawn start with an infant under the care
of Nora tribe outcast Ross she becomes
playable as a small child who
desperately wants to be part of the
community but is constantly shunned
ignored and avoided children jam with me
she's an outcast to be shunned the world
is now overrun by mechanical dinosaurs
and understanding how this happened is a
core element of the story we are
introduced to the reaction system after
a young tribe boys throw the rock at a
line allowing us to react with our heart
our head or our fists although they seem
to be superficial choices they do allow
the player to mold a lie into the person
that they want her to be a lie
accidentally falls into an ancient
bunker and stumbled across a focus this
small device allows a log to interact
with ancient technology as well as
enhancing her perception of the world
around her
three
Kaspar red ruffed attempts to take the
divisors from her but luckily for the
story while he is unable such things are
dangerous
now the next story B is uncovered a lie
begins to wonder who her mother is and
why she is an outcast as rust is a
surrogate father and an outcast himself
he's unable to answer those questions
but he does know where that she can get
answers there is a way perhaps he'll
tell me it will be dangerous how it
would take years of training I don't
care how do I do it tell me the proving
the tribes right a passage held every
year those who pass become Braves but to
the one who wins the matriarch granted
boom yes ever the winner wants and I'll
do it
please repeat
[Music]
I'll then approval we best get started
then your training will be hard thank
you
start training yeah follow fast forward
several years Li is now a young woman a
highly skilled tactical mastermind with
Bo and staff enhance her devotion to
finding answers about still her mother
is and why she is an outcast has led her
to the proving which seems to be a final
test for young members of the tribe a
light enters her homeland for the first
time and in our of the community one man
in particular stands out to a large you
to the fork as he possesses all in looks
to be hiding something and doesn't have
any time for our hero we'll get back to
him very soon like a proving begins and
guess who a Lloyd main rival is none
other than the boy who threw the stone
at her as a child and he hasn't changed
little [ __ ] your trophy is shattered
outcast looks like you'll need another
against all of a like somehow wins the
proving didn't win the out castrated and
I'll just win the proving never
but she is a brave now
did it as all you all so long as you put
your trophy on the altar but I did a
loin once outcast and now brave who is
first among the Nara tribe are attacked
a nice earning amount of Nora died
including that storm throwing booger
from earlier so every cloud has a silver
lining and all that a lie is able to
take out many of the attacking cultists
who coincidentally are also wearing
focuses just as a annoyed life was about
to be extinguished in come rock to save
his non biological doctor but he is no
match for cook leader helix
hey lie
why
[Music]
our IB roast
Eli wigs back in the Nora homeland and
is being nursed back to health by met
react Easter CSO reveals that a lie was
found as a baby on the worshipping altar
which looks more like a doll but it
won't open at this point
Tina saw a Lloyd's birth as a blessing
to the tribe but the other major react
start has occurred and that's why a lie
was given to an outcast to raise need to
do that
Eli tracks down all in for two reasons
one he was wearing a focus and two he
didn't look too trustworthy earlier on
all in admits that he's been helping a
satanic cult known as the Eclipse who
worship a demon named Hades Hades has
given them the power to control machines
in all in defense he is only helping to
prolong the life of his family who are
being held captive speaking of the
forces device that Li wears there seems
to be some sort of communication device
to it kind of like a Bluetooth headset a
mysterious chap going by the name silent
watch's a life travel occasionally he
chirps him with support and information
but he seems very sly and untrustworthy
to me how monumental are the discoveries
you just made three laws following all
in enforce a law travels to markers rise
and being able to enter the ancient
building due to her genetic similarities
to dr. Elizabeth cervix upon locating
text files and hollow projections we
uncover what happened to the world
almost 1000 years ago
in short the robots were created to work
for mankind they were even given the
ability to feed on biological elements
so things like grass and trees and sadly
even people after a glitch in the
programming the robots could no longer
be controlled and decided to wipe out
humanity the last surviving members of
the human race took part in project zero
dance in order to save the world or and
if you want the culprit for all this
the chaps called Ted far-off a light is
captured by the Eclipse cult and its
fastest fight without her focus
luckily the mysterious islands bricks
are out and the two escaped relatively
unharmed
a few more discoveries and many more
DynaVox supported Assad we learn more
about project zero dawn humanity's
finest minds created Gaia an artificial
intelligence designed to give life to
the earth once the machines destroy it
and hope for themselves to Gaia would
first initiate plant life and that the
terraforming the planet would eventually
repopulate the globe using cloning
technology this was in fact 974 years
ago Gaia is also referred to as mother
nature in AI form which has eight
subsets characteristic such as Poseidon
for revitalizing the ocean and Apollo
for educating the clone children the
most volatile one looks to be Hades and
if you're paying attention earlier you
would remember the Eclipse cult who were
dedicated to heading in sha the Hades
system was designed to destroy life on
Earth if the redevelopment didn't go to
plan
somehow Hades became self-aware Gaia
responded by self-destructing the prime
reactor which would hopefully destroy
Hades but definitely destroy Gaia - JD's
somehow managed to survive his
termination by jumping to the closest
functional computer core thus trapping
himself
Gaia's final act before the prime
reactor blew her to smithereens was to
create a light by using Elizabeth
kerbecs DNA gaia hope that in the years
ago she would know how to save the earth
once again Elizabeth I know you too well
somehow you will find a way in you all
things are possible
go to the rooms of Gaia Prime find the
control room and within the master
override Hades must be destroyed
as on I only wish they'd like to show
your voice again with the help of
silence a lie locates the system
override data needed to destroy Hades
and just as we understand what needs to
be done the mysterious man has something
to tell us
I was there at the beginning I found
hidden in line buried on that mountain
trapped in the shadowed pedal and I
served it Valens was the founder of the
Eclipse cult and was responsible for
freeing and upgrading Hades until the
demon AI no longer needed him silence
thirst for knowledge has been evident
throughout the story but even he knows
he has to make amends Salle's gifts a
liar new staff capable of destroying
Hades and the final battle is almost
here with Hades attempting to terminate
all life on Earth a like quickly gathers
her allies and of course their army - I
haven't had a chance to tell you about
watch Eve sauna or Petra or usage or
even tab - all pitch in during the final
fight as long as you complete their
specific side craft of course the final
battle is furious but a light and her
associates defeat the new cult leader
healer and using silent staff a lie and
the war
[Music]
to activate state name and right price
masterful derive activated purging
extinction protocol
[Applause]
Eloy travels to find Elizabeth's or
Beck's body and said goodbye to the
mother she never knew if you had had a
child a little bit what would you have
wished for him or her I guess I would
have wanted her to be curious
[Music]
and willful unstoppable even but with
enough compassion to heal the world just
a little bit
[Music]
after the credits roll we are given one
final cook theme depicting daddy's
consciousness being trapped by silence I
told you I'd entrust that booger
hello old friend
remember me
we still so much to discuss
let's begin
that's it that's a whistle-stop tour of
horizon zero dawn I hope that story made
sense to you I try to keep to the core
story but there are many little subtle
elements that make this game an instant
classic so bloody place if you haven't
already I imagine from PlayStation
grenades please Chuck us a like and
subscribe for more video game stories
see you next time